victime d'une grave blessure à la
cheville et au dos lors d'un saut en
parachute lorsqu'elle était au gign
margot boulet a su faire preuve de
résilience lors des jeux paralympiques
de tokyo elle a décroché la médaille de
bronze en aviron elle était présente
mercredi 17 novembre au centre ouest
field vélizy 2 pour présenter son
parcours en tant que marraine du
programme scola
quand on m'a proposé en fait de
parrainer cette à cette promotion qu'on
m'a expliqué le concept dont j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait un certain parallèle entre
mon parcours l'accident ait cette chance
que j'ai eue de pouvoir rebondir ainsi
une chance aussi qu'on m'a proposé je
suis pas arrivé tout seul est ce qu'on
la perd mais aussi à ça c'est jeune et
j'ai trouvé que c'était très beau
c'était à la fois aux et audacieux et
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup que ces concepts
j'étais disponible donc j'étais ravi de
pouvoir venir le programme scola porté
par les apprentis d'auteuil permet à des
jeunes peu ou non diplômés d'accéder à
l'emploi sur des secteurs en tension
comme la vente pendant deux heures ils
ont pu échanger et présenter leurs
boutiques à margaux boulet un moment
enrichissant des deux côtés ça ne peut
que malgré à vienne main qu'un accident
qu'elle a eue
elle a continué elle est devenue
championne
ça dure que tout est possible d'autant
que j'ai pas eu d'accident suis en forme
c'est à dire que j'ai toutes les chances
de
de réussir juste il faut croire en soi
de vouloir
déterminer s'inspirant j'ai dit j'ai
discuté avec les stagiaires et sarah
donner du jus de l'espoir
donc c'est important d'avoir des gens
comme ça vraiment tout est possible tant
qu'on ait envie un message fort que marc
boulet souhaité délivrer aux stagiaires
du programme scola de quoi les rebooster
pour réussir leurs examens de fin
d'année et se fixer de nouveaux
objectifs